was sind ihre vorsätze eigentlich fürs
neue jahr was ist da ein toller vorsatz
wirst ja ich finde es immer schon super
wenn man jeden tag
also wenn das schon mal gemacht ist ein
häkchen ich bin mir da nichts großes vor
aber wir haben ja viele promis
nachgefragt manche hängen die ziele ganz
ganz hoch und manchen gehen dass er so
an wie ich und sagen na schauen wir mal
wir sehen jetzt einfach mal rein ins
neue jahr wären zb nachgefragt bei
schlagersänger bernhard brink und das
oder das weniger hat er sich vorgenommen
ich habe für dieses jahr wirklich nichts
vorgenommen wir stehen wunderbare
jubiläen an und dafür brauche ich alle
power deswegen hoffe ich für mich
persönlich dass ich gesund bleibe und
das wünsche ich ihnen allen auch von
herzen diesem sinne neuer genannt bringt
also nichts hat davor schlagersänger
bernhard brink und das ist vielleicht
auch manchmal eine ganz schöne menge sex
ja aber millionen deutsche haben ja
wünsche gute vorsätze für das jahr
2022 aber noch nicht mal richtig
vorgenommen schon sind sie wieder
gebrochen die guten vorsätze so geht es
vielen ja viele werden schon im keim
erstickt bevor es überhaupt losgeht denn
auch wenn uns mal anschauen wie die
deutschen es mit den guten vorsätzen in
diesem jahr halten und das zeigt eine
aktuelle umfrage das haben sich die
menschen also vorgenommen und auf platz
eins ganz weit oben liegt stress abbauen
und mehr zeit mit der familie und dann
auf platz zwei kommt direkt
klimafreundlicher leben und dann das
hatte ich ja auf platz eins erwartet so
geht es auch meistens los mehr sport
treiben das nehmen sich immerhin 59
prozent der deutschen vor der zeit für
sich selbst gesünder ernähren abnehmen
weniger zeit mit dem handy und am
computer sparsamer seien weniger
fernsehen.de weniger alkohol trinken das
rauchen aufgeben dann auf dem letzten
jahr und so viele von diesen guten
vorsätzen sind so wahnsinnig schwer
einzuhalten sind so wahnsinnig schwer zu
erreichen dabei helfen wir ihnen in
diesem jahr in 20 22 nicht wir sondern
vor allen dingen er unser spar volksbank
ochse hilft dabei was ist das für eine
tolle bild aktion frank für alle die es
noch nicht mitbekommen haben was macht
ihr vieh helft ihr den deutschen beim
einhalten ihrer guten vorsätze ja frohes
neues jahr und dazu gehören natürlich
auch gute vorsätze und kumpel von mir
hat gleich gepostet menschlich war am
neujahrsmorgen gleich im
schnellrestaurant da haben die guten
vorsätze natürlich zehn stunden oder so
gehalten wir wollen natürlich dass das
länger hält und wir haben eine tolle
aktion nämlich den vorsatz booster von
bild und david dabei geht es darum dass
sich leser und zuschauer bei uns
bewerben wir helfen mit einem coach mit
einem experten damit dass auch
tatsächlich bis ins neue jahr reicht und
dann wenn bis zum 15 februar ein ziel
was vorher definiert wird erreicht wird
dann gibt es 1000 euro vorsatz belohnung
also gibt es auf jeden fall auch den
anreiz natürlich durchzuhalten und
unsere zuschauer haben sich wirklich mit
tollen vorsätzen beworben also zum
beispiel aufräumen klamotten wegwerfen
natürlich auch abspecken mehr sport also
insofern ist da die ganze palette da
oder zum beispiel ein zuschauer hat
geschrieben er hat ein lied komponiert
aber das müsste jetzt irgendwann mal
verändert werden auch da versuchen wir
natürlich zu helfen wir haben die aktion
noch bis morgen also bis morgen können
sich die leser und zuschauer noch bei
uns bewerben und vielleicht werden sie
an genau das musste nochmal sagen also
für alle die gute vorsätze haben und
jetzt schon so ein bisschen schwanken
aber es gibt noch eine chance bei ihnen
den guten vorsatz einzuhalten sie
kriegen hilfe bei uns beim spar volks
frank ochse wie können sie sich bewerben
also ist wirklich total einfach einfach
eine e mail schicken an 1414 bild.de und
auf jeden fall natürlich ein foto mit
senden oder auch ein video kann man auch
per whatsapp schicken mit seinem vorstoß
einfach aussprechen im handy unter 01 71
592 2 1 1 und dann die redaktion
scheckter inwiefern können wir da helfen
haben wir da einen experten damit es
auch wirklich auch gelingt und dann gibt
es praktisch die nachricht sie sind dann
dabei und wir werden sie dann begleiten
unsere zuschauer und leser dokumentieren
dann ihre erfolge praktisch auch mit
handy videos oder fotos
er ist an sich schon viele per
videobotschaft beworben und da wollen
wir jetzt mal reinschauen bei
krankenschwester romy berner zb und bei
carl zeiss aus berlin denn der hat ja
man kann sagen ein süßes problem
ich möchte mein bild gewinnspiel
20 22 teilnehmen und meine sucht möchte
ich euch sagen es dieses jahr von
marzipan ich drehe fast durch und möchte
aber diese sucht loswerden und da kam
mir bild genau zum richtigen zeitpunkt
hilft mir damit ich davon loskommen und
ich werde es schaffen mit eure hilfe und
mit der hilfe meiner frau mit meinem
kleinen sohn und so gehen wir das an wir
wollen fünf kilo mindestens wir kriegen
und vor allen dingen die sucht ja mohn
marzipan was ja unheimlich cooles muss
fällt das klingt aber auch christlich
mona ziegler muss man das überhaupt
loswerden er hat sich dafür entschieden
und es ist auch lobenswert bei uns ich
bin besser jetzt zugeschaltet karl heinz
seitz größe sehr herzlicher salz cup
gehört sie haben heute geburtstag also
alles liebe von handy saß der uci und
wir schenken kein eis
vielen vielen dank
ich bin jetzt bereit für die größte zu
den größten kampf da sich diese sucht
hier in griff bekommen natürlich auch
ironisch gemeint aber ich merke halt
dass ich seit einem monat da wirklich in
einer blöden corona sucht verfallen bin
die so nicht gut ist und ich mir für
mein neues jahr und natürlich jetzt zu
meinem geburtstag
wünschen würde dass ich davon loskommen
was kosten sich mit wieviel becher eis
da ja in sie reingekommen ich finde den
vergangenen wochen hatten
da ist es die sucht ja und das ist
unwahrscheinlich scheint bloß nie sowas
an das ist massiv an und das ist man
darf es gar nicht sagen das sind 6 150
milliliter es ja wahnsinn und wenn ich
dann abends alleine bin ich warte
natürlich weil ich ein bisschen gefühl
haben ich denke lassen meine kleinen
familien
gehen ich habe ja noch einen kleinen
sohn mit einer jungen hübschen frau und
der junge mann der macht mich natürlich
sehr glücklich und ich möchte das auch
noch lange miterleben müssen ja das ist
ja auch zu und suchten ich hab es durch
zufall gelesen dass wir so was macht das
jetzt leute vielleicht helfen könnte und
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass ich
das mit hilfe und mit meinem verstand
schossen mit der hilfe von
ernährungsexperten doktor an affleck
denn die wollen wir jetzt in unser
gespräch reinholen schön dass sie bei
uns sind und sie haben sicherlich tipps
wie man von solchen schlechten
angewohnheiten von so einer art sucht
nach süßen nach zucker hier im
speziellen fall eines monats japan
wieder wegkommt wird
und ich freue mich so dass ich jetzt was
denn mit dem monitor werfen kann sie
haben eine lösung ihres problems
sie haben eine wunderbare familie und
egal was wir vornehmen
was wir verändern wollen dazu braucht es
ein motiv denn motivation juden machen
und das ist einfach du
musst immer kurz jemand aus der leitung
around ist auch gesünder zu leben wenn
dinge schieflaufen ist nicht als
katastrophe zu bewerten also auch nicht
mal jedes als als schrecklich zu
bewerten sondern sie stellt geht's
visuell und allerdings zuschauen etwas
vor sich selbst was möchten sie waren
sie alt werden und ich kann ja einfach
nur vorstellen sie wollen mit ihrem sohn
und ihrer familie die mit ihrer lieben
frau gesund vital ohne schmerzen ohne
über nicht ohne diabetes demenz und
krebs eignen und das müssen sie sich
vorstellen und dann an die riesige hürde
getan es liegt auch danach sahen sie ein
emotionaler es also jemand der im moment
nicht gefühlte gefühle sowie mit
soßenbinder bindet auch das ist für
viele menschen ein riesiges problem das
sollten sie war ein bisschen liebe folge
joker auspacken und nach schon woran das
liegen könnte und wie bekommt man jetzt
einfach auf dem alltag eine gesündere
struktur es kommt hier gar nicht darauf
an was sie essen sondern auch wie oft
und wann sie essen und hier dann
einfacher tipp starten sie in den tag
nicht mit dem café gleich mit zwei
großen gläser wasser und sie können mit
einem anfang ist der mannschaft für die
verdauung wird die weg die vertrauen das
übrigens in bester fordert ihr stärkstes
immunsystem auf dem verhindern von krebs
oder in der abwehr von viren die gerade
gar nicht so gerne haben und dann essen
sie bitte ab geht's nun und man sieht
ein ehrliches und ein ganz einfaches
rezept ich natürlich selbst mache und
ein patient machen der praxis gerne und
mit viel erfolg empfehle setzen sie auf
ein stück also frühstücken sind nicht
mehr sondern erst später wenn die
technik hunger haben und damit aber zum
beispiel die kombination aus einer so
und fett wählen weil die hat einen
weniger stark blute bereits das heißt
sie haben auch nicht gleich wieder
einmal beispiel die hohle hand von müsse
müsse
bioanteil operieren sich geht und dann
fand ich sehr sehr langes
sättigungsgefühl also diese das so im
brötchen mit wurst ist dann die perfekte
entzündungs kombination mit dem marzipan
und ansonsten wenn sie sich jetzt mit
der familie was kochen dann nimmt die
diese prinzip des gesunden tellers mit
heute kamen sie sich die hälfte des
tellers mit grünzeug voll war das ist
man füllt es mit auto tankt er will erst
mal voll wären alle stoffe nährstoffe
eine handtellergroße ein heißt also aus
ihrer vorliebe auf das jetzt des pcs
stück geflügel ist und am abstiegs und
kohlenhydraten und und mais kartoffeln
über die sparsam sein und hätten sie
gesagt sie sollen nicht hungern das
leben ist zu kurz um irgendwie durchs
leben zu maschinen und halten sie sich
jeden tag jetzt im motiv von bleiben sie
besser bewusst dazu sagen das ganze war
ein emotionaler esser das würde ich für
mich auch in anspruch nehmen also ganz
tolle tipps frau doktor flex sie werden
ab jetzt kontrollieren wie vielen dank
es welcher da noch ins haus kommen tag
für die super tipps und wir haben noch
jemanden den wir begleiten durch dieses
jahr der guten vorsätze patricia ja ganz
genau das ist krankenschwester romy
bernhard und sie hat sich was
vorgenommen sie es uns jetzt
zugeschaltet und bei ihnen soll es in
diesem jahr richtig sportlich zugehen
frau bern hat
genau ich möchte endlich
sportlich werden sportlicher werden
ja das funktioniert so nicht mehr dass
ich wirklich nahezu gar nichts an sport
mache und die idee kamen wir
letztendlich oder so ein bisschen der
anspruch in dem mein mann das große ziel
hat den marathon mitzulaufen in
amsterdam gut das werde ich nicht
erreichen so realistisch muss man sein
aber mich zumindest mehr bewegung und
ein ziel dann ist von mir dachte ich mir
ein halbmarathon zumindest zu schaffen
und wenn ich jetzt für mich so alleine
mal losgeht zu zocken spätestens nach
fünf minuten kann ich einfach nicht mehr
habe ich den anspruch nicht und hat sich
das gestern nach nachtdienst gelesen und
dachte jetzt oder nie jetzt versuche ich
es und dann noch vielleicht mit hilfe
von irgend so ein coach der mir etwas
anschauen gibt während das optimal das
heißt sie sind bisher im grunde
überhaupt nicht gelaufen und steuern in
diesem jahr 2022 auf ein halbmarathon
richtig
genau so ist das und wie sehr geht ihnen
da das muffensausen dass man das auch
schafft wenn sie sind bei uns gelandet
wir geben ihnen ja dem booster dafür wir
stellen ihnen ja profis dann an die
seite um dieses ziel auch zu erreichen
dennoch denke ich mir wenn man bisher
jetzt nicht unbedingt jeden tag sport
gemacht hat und es sowieso in seinem
leben integriert hat ist es erst mal ein
gewaltiger schritt von dem man
wahrscheinlich auch erst mal ganz schön
respekt hat oder
ja doch habe ich aber ich bin wirklich
guter dinge geraten
wenn dir jemand an die seite gestellt
wird wenn wir im profi an die seite
gestellt wird dass wir das dann zusammen
erreichen und
das dass ich das schaffen kann was genau
wir wir sind auch guter dinge frau
bernhard wir begleiten sie dabei das ist
ein fall für unser ansparfonds frank
auxerre übernimmt an dieser stelle hilft
ihnen auf dem weg zum halbmarathon den
sie in 2022 schaffen werden danke dafür
dass sie regelmäßig die tollen bild
aktion